a new book is urging people to embrace
the awkward moments and discuss race
openly and honestly the book is called
real friends talk about race Bridging
the gaps through uncomfortable
conversations the authors are Hannah
Summerhill and Izu mukan tabana they met
in 2019 and created the kinswomen
podcast on the same topic is Rwandan
born in Burundi and raised in Burundi
Belgium and the United States and Summer
Hill is from Pennsylvania both are
Jewish good morning good to see you both
good morning this is such an important
and timely conversation I'm so happy to
have the both of you here yeah
um is it how did you both meet
so we met at a co-working space focused
for only women
and it was at an event that was exactly
speaking about the subject in matter
and it was kind of like a fishbowl type
of conversation where people were
invited to join the moderators and I
found it really uh problematic in a
sense that like most of the people there
were white were white women
and most of the women coming into the
fish bowl conversation were women of
color and it felt very voyeuristic okay
so instead of me coming in and adding on
to like this like trauma narrative that
was being very vulnerably shared
um I came in and called out the the
obvious and I was like why isn't the
majority coming in and participating
actively and addressing the issue and
that's where Hannah was one of these
people and she came after and said oh I
liked what you said and it made sense it
it it spoke to her and that's from from
that we became friends and we stayed in
contact and the rest is history podcast
books all of that later but why is it so
important Hannah for white people to
engage in these conversations which as
you both write about can be very
uncomfortable sometimes absolutely yeah
I think it's uncomfortable for us
because we just don't have the capacity
for it and we don't have the
socialization we are our society really
avoids talking about discomfort and I
think it brings a lot of guilt and shame
for a lot of white people but we really
Advocate through our podcast and book to
lead into the discomfort discomfort does
not kill you and these import these
conversations are so important because
we all live in a global Society but we
really don't necessarily understand as
white people what's happening with our
colleagues of color our friends of color
our family members of color and there's
a lot of trust that's been lost over the
centuries of white supremacy
so in the interpersonal interactions
that we have I think often we think oh
we're starting on neutral ground but
there are so many layers underneath that
and that's really what we try to talk
about and bring light too and there are
different ways or shall say different
Vehicles we can use to communicate which
is why I love chapter eight social
justice on social media I thought
something powerful was written it's
important to remember that our seemingly
insignificant opinions online can create
a snowball effect of bad information
that can make people uncomfortable and
sometimes even unsafe in this day and
age seems like everybody's quick to jump
on social media yeah yeah I know what
I'm talking about well I think I know
what I'm talking about I hope I know
what I'm talking about forget it's the
thought that counts yes right so why is
it important to address the social media
side of people speaking out but yeah I
mean Easter and I are Millennial women
so we spend a lot of our time on social
media and it's increasingly a space
where Millennials and others get their
news and information so so we there's
ways that racism can present online that
I think as white people we have a
responsibility to be aware of if we're
perpetuating or not yeah and and I think
that like social media can be a really
helpful tool of course I think a lot of
people are doing amazing work uh bypoc
are really taking time to teach to
educate and to like bring people
together and I think that on the other
side well-meaning allies are seeking to
be allies what people will use that as a
way to kind of like uh present
themselves to to the world as one of the
good ones and like in reality you should
be able to take that as a tool to
think outside of what you know or like
to it's not it shouldn't be used as a
way to prove what you are it should be
used as a way to nourish your
understanding of the world that you live
in right and if people understand it
like that and use it like that I think
it would be amazing but as of now it's
just yeah so so one of the things that
you write about which is oftentimes
people will say especially in this day
and age sometimes they do it from a
place of genuine sincere sincerity but
sometimes it's cynical you write this
many of us will point to prominent and
Wealthy black people like Barack Obama
Oprah and Beyonce to try to disprove our
society's racial hierarchy as if
singular success could make up for
centuries of stolen land and labor
medical bias the wealth Gap police
brutality so on and so on why do you
think that people some and you this is
you this is in your voice Hannah why do
you think that sometimes people will
point out and say well you know we had a
black president what are you complaining
about we really believe in this country
of a myth of meritocracy and we we
ignore all the systemic racism you know
From Slavery to Jim Crow to the prison
pipeline to the war on drugs and it's so
important for us to have context of this
and we can't just point to exceptional
people who have probably had to work
three times as hard and say oh
everything's fine because really yeah we
had one black president out of how many
so it's really unfair to act like
there's parody when we just see a few
examples so when you hear somebody say
that to you what goes through your mind
do you think that they're being and this
is why I've said that sometimes people
say cynically and sometimes people say
it from genuine sincerity right
I don't even know when it is like I
don't know if people that say that
actually can place themselves as being
cynical or being genuinely like oh this
is a proof I think that people use that
as a tool to try to manage the reality
that's really overwhelming that things
are systematic and that even if a few
like when uh went through the cracks it
doesn't explain the the magnitude of the
state of things right and and I think
it's a misunderstanding of how things
are working it's and it's not looking at
individual it's more about the system of
course yeah such an important point this
is such a great book it really is and
the podcast is amazing thank you both
for being here appreciate so much for
having us of course yeah real friends
talk about race goes on sale tomorrow
we'll be right back